e
de l'huile de tournesol à la pompe c'est
une première en france ce matin à
villeneuve sur lot les bennes à ordures
de la ville ont fait le plein sans
qu'aucune modification ne soit apportée
au moteur diesel
79 centimes le litre contre 1 or aucun
pour le gazon
je peux faire la même chose le moteur
ans et aucun chagement dessus aucun
changement technique c'est un moteur
zina je crois 180 km h pendant la
tournée rien à signaler
pour l'heure le mélange comprend
seulement 30 % d'huile
mais bientôt tout fonctionnera au
tournesol pour les éboueurs familier des
odeurs le pot d'échappement diffuse même
d'un parfum à gré au mollet tempête qui
l'on doit le monde est là mais une odeur
très saine c'est le maire qui a souhaité
que ces camions roulent à huile végétale
mais le droit français autorise ce
carburant que pour le matériel agricole
ce partisan du tournesol s'appuie donc
sur une directive européenne de 2003
prévoit une utilisation sans nulle nous
sommes donc parfaitement dans la
légalité ici les choses sont pas sept
poteau c'est tout simplement parce que
depuis 2003 les pouvoirs publics ne
souhaite pas que ce type d'initiative se
développe tout simplement pour des
raisons de rentrées fiscales
autre avantage de l'huile de tournesol
elle est non polluant que sont les
agriculteurs de la région qui la
produisent un débouché dans un
département où beaucoup de terres sont
en jachère forcé l'espoir c'est que bon
ça soit l'agriculteur qui développe
cette filière que ça soit pas un
industriel pour ce spécialiste du
carburant végétal le tournesol peut
alimenter une bonne part du parc
automobile
on va avoir un million huit d'hectares
leurs jachères en 2008 que je serais un
million huit hectares on pourrait
produire évidemment des l'énergie donc
j'ai eu du talent pur à destination de
la combustion donc ce qui nous
représenterait à peu près un million
mythe de tonnes équivalent pétrole
ce qui est tout à fait énorme maintenant
déjà d'autres vivent se montrent
intéressés c'est ce qu'espère et
villeneuve sur lot un effet à genoux